j'ai fait une très belle rencontre il ya
quelques jours j'ai fait une très belle
rencontre avec une dame qui a 62 ans qui
est célibataire qui est retraitée elle
était venue pour soutenir la cause et
gilet jaune
elle gagne 1000 13 euros par mois et
c'est très difficile pour elle toutes
les fins de mois
regardez où j'ai rencontré cette
personne vous êtes jeanine jeanine sert
à jeanine où il est né 1000 euros par
mois alors vous pouvez pas faire de
cadeau à vos petits enfants nous
maintenons parce que depuis que je suis
en retraite au moins deux mon budget a
été totalement réduits et en plus je
dois payer sens et on me prend 110 euros
de csg jeu pour vous inviter le 19
oui je vous fera cadeau noël pas aux
petits enfants ah non là si ça veut peut
dire que je suis comme ça avec la zone
euro du mal mais je rigole avec toi tu
n'es ramon est inquiète pas
[Applaudissements]
oh
jeanine
merci le cloud nine merci beaucoup
jeanine jeanine m'étais toujours au
gilet jaune en fait j'ai fait un gros
bisou jeanine merci d'être là à tous et
que tu m'a beaucoup touché quand tu
étais venu me voir avec ton gilet jaune
avec ton histoire dans balances ton post
je t'avais dit qu'on allait se revoir
oui je voulais vraiment que tu sois avec
mon soir avant les fêtes parce que tu as
six enfants ou là des petits enfants
regardent vas voir ta famille et tu nous
disais tu rêvais de garder catete
enfants et tous tes petits enfants de
noël mais que tu n'avais pas les moyens
tu nous avais raconté son histoire mille
13 euros par mois et ce soir j'ai envie
de leur faire plaisir
jeanine regarde ce que j'ai pour tes
petits enfants
c'est pour toutes
[Applaudissements]
c'est assez des cadeaux président mais
c'est un petit cadeau pour toi c'est que
on avait un petit message je vais te
dire que je t'aime très fort que je suis
fier d'avoir une mère comme toi je sais
que la vie ne t'a pas forcément gâté
voilà l'évêché mais d'embûches mais tu
t'es toujours rejouer des mamies
formidable c'était donc voilà je tenais
à te faire cette petite vidéo pour te
dire à quel point tu étais de mam est
formidable
donc on a mis ses tirages voulait que
c'est qu'un jeune noah qui montre trop
faux bijoux
[Musique]
je pense tous les cadeaux pour eux et
j'avais envie de tout faire aussi un
pack électro high tech pour toi voilà
tout voilà home cinéma tout ça parce que
pour que tu puisses me regarder
qu'est ce que vous allez faire là avec
la famille tu va les voir là bientôt
oui on doit se voir le 29 passes quand
commandé beaucoup
d'accord on les paie le fait chaque
année cadeaux moi j'ai envie vous voyez
un petit peu plus avec ta famille donc
je vous offrir un séjour à courchevel
avec location de skis forfaits de ski
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je le fais des normes bisous et ne
change rien à cette énorme pour tout ce
qu'elle a fait avec les avec les gilet
jaune parce qu'elle était sur le terrain
à la fin avance et les choses est
vraiment exceptionnel
bravo
[Applaudissements]
non